Зараз ми маємо продовжити мобілізацію
для українців але за поза всіма
факторами не тільки Московська агресія
вина в тому що ми зараз маємо Шукати тих
хто буде боронити державу а одним із
перших причин в цьому всьому є те що я
так розумію що можна владі до досі не
дійшло що війна триває з лютого
2014 року і я зараз вимагаю вибачення
усієї моно влади перед родинами загиблих
постраждалих внутрішньо переміщених осіб
14 по 22-й рік яких ви не хочете Ані
бачите і не знати бо ви всі заглядали в
очі путіни розказували які будуть у
травні шашлики другий момент
допоки у нас сидить п'ята в псжна колона
в залі про які нормальні результати ми
можемо говорити зливають все що можна
зливають яка тут мотивація для наших
бійців але ж не опзж зараз гарно
підголосовуємо на Владі і разом невідомо
чим займаються але точно на роботу і на
перемогу Української держави Я хотіла би
нагадати також що те що дехто тут в залі
понадягав зелені сорочки не означає що
ви воювали що ви розумієтеся в тому що
зараз там є на фронті А я ще нагадаю що
з 19-го року були зупинені ракетні
програми було запущене скорочення армії
на 100 000 було б переслідування
ветеранів волонтерів бойових генералів
всьо що тільки можна аби тільки
послабити Українську Державу і так зараз
мобілізація треба Але вона потрібна
через мотивацію а мотивація йде через
довіру до держави де цінується життя
кожного бійця де не дерибанять гроші в
Міністерства охорони культури і всіх
інших сферах де не гуляють по закордонах
А де забезпечують армію усіма можливими
способами вибачення для загиблих героїв
негайно